if you live each day as if it was your
last someday you'll most certainly be
right it made an impression on me and
since then for the past 33 years I've
looked in the mirror every morning and
asked myself if today were the last day
of my life what I want to do what I am
about to do today and whenever the
answer has been no for too many days in
a row I know I need to change something
remembering that I'll be dead soon is
the most important tool I've ever
encountered to help me make the big
choices in life because almost
everything all external expectations all
pride all fear of embarrassment or
failure these things just fall away in
the face of death leaving only what is
truly important remembering that you are
going to die is the best way I know to
avoid the trap of thinking you have
something to lose it's ha
easy it's not an option it's hard living
life is hard she's hard when when you
are 49 years old and working on a job
for 17 years and they come in and tell
you you're finished give you one week
severance pay you got to start all over
again it's hard when you're married and
raising children and your children are
crawling and your husband dies
unexpected it's hard handling just the
tragedies of life it's hard when you're
working on something in and you put
everything you have in it and it doesn't
work out you know teenage mom got
pregnant at 17 you know um and you know
I just been felling my whole life ma'am
I'll do didn't come in my life and I was
about 30 dropped out of high school to
12 years to get a four-year degree and
I'm like I mastered Feli
you know
we can look at a laundry list of
billionaires who started with absolutely
nothing and ultimately got to where they
wanted to be Sam walk Ralph Lauren
Howell ham David Murdoch Howard Schultz
Oprah Winfrey Larry Ellison all these
people started from absolutely nothing
the problem with most people is that
you're not obsessed with employee you're
obsessed with making money
you're obsessed with taking your
business to the next oh I cannot be
honest with you guys when you become
obsessed with improvement I will spend
more time learning and Australia then I
will speaking I'm a said again because
you missed it I will spend more time
sitting under people I will spend more
time learning that I will speaking in
this country I will walk away with stuff
I never heard before books I've never
read before audios I've never seen
before one of the conference's that I've
never gone hanging out with people that
I've never hung out with before this is
nothing god this is just a desert mate
speaking his destin'd desert this is
just the beginning
I came to Australia to learn I came to
Australia to get upgrade when I go back
my wife will notice the difference
my kids were no different why I'm
obsessed with improvement every day I'm
getting better there those of you with
phones and every new phone that comes
out you get it every upgrade you get it
every piece of software you get it you
are upgrading your technology and you've
not upgraded yourself what do you how do
you hang in there during the hard
difficult I'm blessed you must have
faced you've got to believe in yourself
you've got to believe in your abilities
you've got to believe in your service
your company your ideas unquestionably
you got to have faith and that faith
gives you patience
there's not going to happen as quickly
as you want it to have lot of things are
going to happen that will catch you off
guard and so therefore you've got to
deal with and handle it as it comes and
not only that but that stage and
patience drives you into action you got
to keep moving and keep plugging away
and the Far East have something that's
called the Chinese bamboo tree the
Chinese bamboo tree takes five years to
grow and when they go through a process
of growing it they have to water and
fertilize the ground where it is every
day and it doesn't break through the
ground until the fifth year but once it
breaks through the ground within five
weeks
it grows 90 feet tall now the question
is does it go 90 feet tall in five weeks
or five years the answer is obvious it
grows 90 feet tall in five years because
at any time that person stopped watering
and nurturing and fertilizing that dream
that bamboo tree would have died in the
ground you've got to keep on watering
your dream
you